the Joe Rogan experience yes you'll
never be around other humans do you know
what happen in the unabomber do you know
how that happened the brother yeah with
it's because he was a pedantic oh yeah
it was that but it was also the
Unabomber
himself Ted Kaczynski be a part of the
Harvard LSD studies was he yeah they
cooked his brain Wow
yeah there's a documentary about it
called the net someone wrote a great
tweet where they go plot twist Greta
Thunderbird grows up to become the
Unabomber in a redemption arc I'm like
that is hilarious it was a very violent
environmentalist very bright man he's a
professor at Berkeley so he went to
school Harvard they put him in the
Harvard LSD studies that cooked his
[ __ ] dome and then he disappeared
went to Berkeley inva worked as a
professor to earn enough money so he
could buy a cabin and implement his plan
to kill everybody who was involved in
technology so he'd stop this takeover of
the human race which probably is true
yeah john waters the director he has a
replica of the Unabomber his cabin as a
room in his house is that great I love
that
who's got the real cabin oh that's a
good question it was at a museum I think
that actually just closed so I don't
know where it's I don't know there was a
museum called the museum and oh yeah
yeah you know I think it's just close
yeah they couldn't traveling exhibit but
they took the whole cabin and
reconstructed it I believe I've seen
pictures of it you need to find a well
that's really cool you need to find and
I love stuff like that I do too I did an
article years ago about all these relics
like where's Monica Lewinsky's dress and
like she's got it hidden somewhere she
she does yeah I daughter could that
people had researched she still has it
oh my god what a nightmare for poor bill
you get your dick sucked in 94 and this
lady's still carrying that just stained
dress like Jesus Christ lady let it go
he's probably not well she's probably
thrown it away by now no no bill never
never listen
oh wow wow I thought that was a replica
I mean it says it was it and that close
huh last week yeah I don't know where
it's at why that isn't they closed last
week I missed it by a week [ __ ] that
could have been out here bro we could
have that probably be inexpensive by
probably like me and Marilyn Manson Oh
affecting others to each other I guess
we're just gonna have to mail someone a
bomb he would probably buy it who Benson
yeah manifesto that's the original holy
crap that's dark everyone tells me to
read it I haven't read it but they said
it's very smart I read parts of it
that's one of the things that's
disturbing is just like well thought out
and also the argument is sound
technology will inevitably lead to
better technology which inevitably leads
to artificial intelligence which is
inevitably gonna take over the world
well there's a whole singularity thing
right what's the Ray Kurzweil Kurzweil
and I don't know I haven't checked in
years but I don't know if we're on track
with what he predicted I think we're
supposed to be further along because
remember in the 50s they're gonna be
flying cars and there's no flying cars
yeah he's a 2045 guy and what he says is
that the exponential increase of
technology if you follow it right the
prediction is somewhere in the
neighborhood of 2045 they'll achieve
this singularity yeah but I think
they're also finding that there actually
is somewhat asymptotic and it does at a
certain point you are having like
physical limitations to increasing the
speed and it's not gonna be that easy
yeah well then quantum supremacy comes
along you know they're trying to change
the name of quantum supremacy because it
confuses people with white supremacy and
we really shouldn't support that so we
need to change quantum supremacy they
also they had was at IBM where whatever
had the quantum computer and the other
people like this isn't really quantum
because of blah blah blah blah
mmm this was a big controversy just in
last month those quantum people I found
its new location after the Montana
Historical Society tried to get it it
now exists at this fun place the FBI
experience they own it so there's like a
interdivisional cooperation FBI
that's the propaganda house Wow
so they wanted to get money so he was in
Montana when he was blown up episode
someone tried to buy the land I guess or
was for sale at one time that the
whoever runs this museum tried to get a
hold of it and if the FBI said we're
gonna keep it yeah I can understand why
they would want to right of course yeah
Wow very valuable people probably will
go to the FBI Museum specifically just
to see that cabin no one wants to go to
the FBI Museum otherwise would you go to
the FBI Museum know his brothers brother
suspect that he was doing it oh you know
I'm for the the manifesto or did he read
the manifesto and then well because the
Unabomber as a kid was always annoyed by
people saying you could have your cake
and eat it too because he's like no no
no it's you can eat your cake and have
it too and the Unabomber used that
phrase
air quotes correctly and the guy's like
that's my brother and that's how they
figured it out cuz he was being a
pedantic dick yeah so everyone who's
correcting people and spelling on
Twitter shut up and relax that's crazy I
thought he just recognized the style of
right and no I I mean I double check me
but I'm 90% sure this is correct you're
saying that New York a can have it too
it's actually ringing a bell yeah god
damn it it's it's imagine like that if
he was a normal guy and they just filled
them up with acid and it made him say oh
my god that technology's gonna take over
and he just started his his calling in
life is to kill the people they're
advancing technology with bombs when
you're that smart you're already kind of
tripping because regular people don't
seem like the same thing as you do right
and maybe a little schizophrenic and
then they fill them up with a [ __ ]
half a gallon of acid like how much did
they give him do you know who knows they
were experimenting with people I'm sure
it's not gonna be small doses you know
what operation midnight climax is now
one of my favorite [ __ ] up
CIA experiments they ever did they went
to brothels and they set up a brothel
with all these prostitutes and these
John's and they dosed all the guys and
use hidden cameras and you know because
the guys couldn't talk about it because
like what happened
Harry somebody gave me a Mickey they
slipped me a Mickey and I had a bad time
where this happened Harry oh I don't
know I guess I was at the diner or
something you can't say I went to the
whorehouse try to get my dick sucked and
they gave me acid these [ __ ] you
can't say that and we've been trained
since kindergarten that if someone says
the CIA has experimented on regular
people they will tell you and admitted
it they will tell you with a straight
face that that's the conspiracy theory
yes they will just use that word and
stop thinking and we've been trained for
decades and it's like wait a minute
we've been hearing three years that
there was a conspiracy between Trump and
the Putin administration that's a
conspiracy but whether it's true or not
Epstein was a conspiracy he was
conspiring with a lot of people yeah
Weinstein Bill Cosby these are all
conspiracies that are widely known but
if you as soon as you hear that term
like racist hmm up conversations over I
don't need to hear anything else that's
amazing oh you believe in conspiracy
theories oh yeah what 9/11 didn't happen
come on
[Applause]